das ist wirklich eine krasse vision der
nasa in zukunft sollen sie schwärmen von
kleinen raumfahrzeugen völlig autonom
durchs all bewegen jetzt gab es einen
großen meilensteine in diesem
zusammenhang in einen streng geheimen
experiment also zunächst strengen ein
waren zwei raumschiffe im all unterwegs
sie sich nicht nur durch wasser antrieb
fortbewegten sondern zudem auch
weitestgehend autonom agieren klicks und
science fiction er gibt es täglich
spannende science - abonniert den kanal
und aktivierte glocken und dann verpasst
ja nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
diese antriebstechnik ist wirklich alles
andere als neu vor rund 200 jahren waren
die dampfmaschinen los und setzten das
industriezeitalter überhaupt erst in
gang das jetzt auch die nasa auf
wasserdampf setzt link nur auf den
ersten blick etwas kurios doch erst im
juni waren tatsächlich zwei kleine
raumschiff im weltall unterwegs die sich
durch wasser antrieb fortbewegt
langfristig gesehen hat die nasa das
ziel dass hunderte von solchen
raumschiffen dem weltraum erkunden und
das völlig autonom laut nasa mitarbeiter
deren lohn sollen dazu in naher zukunft
autonome schwärme von kleinen
raumfahrzeugen organisiert werden
konkret waren es bei dem nasa experiment
kleinen satelliten die zuvor mit dampf
spüren ausgestattet worden waren anders
als in den alten dampfmaschinen treibt
der dampfer also keinen kolbenmotoren
stattdessen gelangt wasser an eine heitz
einheit an der öffnung eines triebwerkes
das aufgeheizte wasser verdampft und
wird aus einer düse versprüht so dass
eine schubkraft erzeugt wird damit sich
ein kleiner satellit in jede richtung
bewegen kann braucht es genau zwölf
düsen
auch wenn die schupp leistung noch
kleiner ist als ein watt und die
satelliten somit nicht besonders schnell
sind ist das völlig ausreichend für die
manöver im all in dem nasa experiment
waren zwei klubs beteiligt sind kleine
raumfahrzeuge entweder größe eines
schuhkartons beide waren etwa neun
kilometer voneinander entfernt dann
bauten sie eine funkverbindung
zueinander auf und näherten sich an und
zwar vollautomatisch der forderung clubs
hat gefehlt dem hinteren über funktional
dass er ihn per wasser antrieb folgen
soll
für die us wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler war dabei nicht nur die
antriebs methode wichtig sondern auch
die autonomie
der beiden raumfahrzeuge laut den plan
der nasa könnten sie sich in zukunft wie
ein drohnen schwarm durch das all
bewegen alle gemeinsam haben sie eine
stationäre basis sie werden organisiert
durch anweisungen und algorithmen und
können somit ihre ziele erreichen doch
klar ist auch ihre ziehen und aufgaben
definieren und verfolgen die mini
flugkörper selbstständig somit führen
sie ihre missionen autonom durch eine
echt klasse vorstellung der schwarm
erledigt einfach alles von selbst wenn
er wenn man ihn sofort ganz einfach die
anweisungen gibt beispielsweise
objektivs oder y zu erkunden sich
fortbewegen mit dampfantrieb könnten sie
dann nicht nur zur erdbeobachtung
eingesetzt werden sondern auch andere
himmelskörper erkunden
bei dem aktuellen experiment waren
jedoch strenge regeln und
sicherheitsvorkehrungen einzuhalten so
wurden die möglichen anweisungen die der
führende cubes hat an den anderen geben
konnte im vorfeld eingeschränkt die
kommandos waren im voraus geplant und
autorisiert dennoch zeigt man das
experiment das sich die raumschiffe
umgehend details ganz eigenständig
kümmern können auch wenn die sequenz von
einem echten menschen infiziert werden
muss dieses super spannende projekt ist
teil des sogenannten smart space kreft
technology programms sscp der nasa und
das scheint erfolgversprechend
voranzukommen vor einigen jahren ging es
nämlich lediglich darum das risiko zu
minimieren und die raumfahrzeuge zu
kalibrieren gras auch das auch noch die
künstlichen intelligenz in diesem
zusammenhang weiter vorangetrieben
werden muss damit die autonomie schwarm
erkundung in ein paar jahren
wirklichkeit werden könnten doch ohne
frage wären raumfahrzeuge die autonome
mal unterwegs sind eine absolut
sinnvolle sache denn funksignale von der
erde kommen äußerst zeitverzögert an bis
zum mars beispielsweise kann es 22
minuten dauern von signalen die sonden
im äußeren sonnensystem erreichen
sondern ganz zu schweigen fusions
antrieb für raumschiffe schon 2028
raumzeit block der zukunft wird jetzt
gleich 100.000 am bus erreichen wenn ihr
den kanal abonnieren und natürlich
dieses video anschaut also draufklicken
anschauen und raumzeit block der zukunft
abonnieren und schon kann der kanal sich
über einen silbernen play button freuen
also bis dann und hier draufklicken
unbedingt und abonnieren
bleibt dran